welcome to another episode of not too
deep the award-winning podcast with me
your host grace Helbig this episode is
fun as they all are
it's James and De Angelis you might know
him from sugar pine 7 you may know him
from the rest in peace' SourceFed you
might know him as a guy that tried to
rent a horse from a stable here in LA
and got denied we learn all about that
on this episode of not too deep we also
learn about this curious hair choices
and what it's like to fight with Steven
septic it's quite a time on this episode
of not too deep with James DeAngelo's is
according to Twitter brought to you by
the OkCupid dating app OkCupid is the
only dating app that finds you someone
based on who you are and what you're
into you can answer all sorts of fun
questions so you can find out if someone
shares your deep love or low thing of
pineapple on pizza or you can
commiserate on your views of the current
state of the world what a spectrum of
fun questions
the OkCupid dating app has awesome
people like you who are into what you're
into so download the free OkCupid dating
app today finally the last of the three
amigos from sp7 sugar pine 7 James D
Angeles named Angela DeAngelis Los
Angeles oh there you go but your twitter
is with the Z with Z yeah it took me a
while to figure that out really just
kept like finding random people named
James Angela focus is doctor I know I
allowed to curse of course you can
[ __ ] curse [ __ ]
yeah why aren't you guys verified on
Twitter that bothers me
Ashton I'm sure it bothers you but it
bothers me no I mean it doesn't bother
me as much because I don't really care
about stuff like that sure would be cool
if like I just woke up one day and it
was like yeah check to Ching and I'd be
like cool now what has been massive on
Twitter for like years yeah yeah and
he's not verified okay so take me
through I've talked to
Cley about this and when Steve was on
here months and months ago he kind of
you know told his side of the story
talk us through meeting them for the
first time what was your first
impressions or what were your first
impressions of them you met at SourceFed
that's Steve at source video okay yeah
cuz you work did you work there before
Steve was there no okay I am see
SourceFed ended I think two years ago in
March and I had gotten hired on the
September I think before that as a PA
fun oh it was the life it was great
because you went to college out here I
went to college in SF okay yeah and how
did you get hired at SourceFed well it's
actually a funny story I applied uh-huh
I like I came back down cuz I'm from
well I was born in Boston but I grew up
in LA like went to high school
everything in LA okay
um went to school up in SF for film
graduated moved back down here with my
girlfriend mm-hmm and just kind of was
doing a little freelance PA jobs here
and there actually worked on some
fullscreen commercials randomly like one
for like these little like go-kart race
car things sure that sounds about right
that's exactly fullscreen or Hot Wheels
and then I was like this isn't cutting
it because I thrive in structure and I
I'm better now but I had a hard time
just holding myself accountable like
finding jobs and sticking with like
making a schedule for myself yeah so I
was like for the time being I'll get a
normal job so I got a job at Arclight
and Hollywood wait what were you doing
there oh just about it anything they
needed oh really
yeah I'm sure you've seen a lot there oh
it sucks yeah it's the worst the only
cool thing from it is like the random
like celebrities you'd see there all the
time yeah I saw Christopher Nolan there
with his family yeah yeah just like over
there I'm just like oh that's Chris
Nolan hey what's up man I saw Spike Lee
perfect he seemed like he was in a hurry
like he liked the movie ended and he
walked out of the theater really quickly
and just like a way that's like that was
Spike Lee
zach braff sure and then anyone else oh
yeah oh oh no this is a good one okay so
I was working ticket taking and it was
the premiere of nocturnal animals okay
and so like I you know you have little
radio thing in huh and I'm hearing like
all right they're coming in through like
the back whatever yeah like they were
gonna do a QA after the movie so they
had Amy Adams and Jake Gyllenhaal there
and so I hear in the radio all right
they're coming in the back right now
psych who's coming in where his I was
like still I think I was like maybe a
few weeks ends so I was still like
getting the hang of everything and in
the lower level that they have like the
entrance to the garage where like
they'll bring the celebrities in and so
I hear the door open like six security
guards just big dudes in suits walk in
and then Amy Adams just like gracefully
floats by and I'm just like oh my god
what like a couple minutes later Jake
Gyllenhaal just like kind of came in on
his own like he was like late she's like
Washington I have such a crush on Jake
Jon huh and I feel a disheveled kind of
late showing up Jake Gyllenhaal somehow
was very attractive you think like well
he was obviously doing something very
important he was late like he was taking
care of something
sure Angie's got a lot on his mind I
just imagined that he was doing
scratch-off tickets you should call this
podcast yeah my offshoot of this it's
gonna be like what's Jake Gyllenhaal
doing is he okay is he scratching off
scratch tickets oh god that would make
me like him even more okay so you worked
at Arclight than you then I got sick of
working at our clay for obvious reason
yes
yeah because I'm tired of seeing
beautiful Amy Adams just float by just
flown here and there no I got tired of
smelling like butter
now at home there's a very fair thing to
be tired so I was like alright well that
was fun
got some free movies out of it huh now
let's get back to the real deal let's
try to apply to something so I went on
the classic entertainment careers net
oh I've yep I am very familiar with that
after I graduated college that was my
like one of the top in my search history
constantly yeah absolutely and I applied
to a PA job and it was for discovery
digital networks which I had no idea
what that was
discovery yeah as a network yeah like
they owned but they owned source so it
was like that for uh in studio like PA
full time I was like cool did that got
the call it got the interview got the
job and I was like cool but I had no
idea what SourceFed was I like knew I
know nothing about YouTube I still don't
yeah welcome to the club yeah it's
pretty it's pretty cool there's just so
much yeah I just started doing that like
did you interview with Phil no no no no
okay with an underling Oh Phil yeah and
then just got right into it started like
it's funny there of the PAS there mm-hmm
wouldn't just do like normal PA jobs I
like set up Lighting's for the set and
like film than camera operated you did
you were so many hats yeah I was like at
the time I was like this is so cool I
get to do all the stuff but looking back
I was like I should have been paid way
yeah I wasn't allowed to be handling
this equipment okay
lesson learned yeah really and then I
met Steve okay and we just hit it off
because like our sense of humor really
similar and we would make each other
laugh yeah and it became a thing like we
would shoot the white wall like news
video things and I would always just be
laughing like behind the camera whenever
Steve would do something stupid and we
have we just became friends he asked me
to shoot a couple of his like videos for
his personal Channel okay and then
SourceFed got canceled
yep and he was like yeah I kind of want
to still be filming stuff and I was like
absolutely if you can pay me the samurai
are similar to what I'm making else I
can sustain this art but I would like
money too oh yeah yeah and then the rest
is history and then the rest is history
so how sugar brain 7 has been 2 years no
two years like actually just look really
cute now oh she's listening to me
nothing never mind Siri yeah two years
like a few days ago that's nuts but you
started as the camera man and then
became a character in this world yeah
how did it was that just an organic
progression I think yeah I mean I love
acting I love being goofy I love um like
all the different aspects of
storytelling whether it's writing like
developing producing directing directing
all that stuff and so I I kind of just
we were all doing everything yeah I was
mostly cameramen at the beginning but we
would all kind of just do everything and
then so I would be on camera sometimes
and there's just like the dynamic of the
three of us yeah worked really well
oh for sure I mean it seems like you
guys have been friends for way longer
than what the timeline actually is your
chemistry is like very natural and
that's what we were talking to Clayton
about it's like the how different you're
like on persona personalities versus off
camera and like when people come up to
you like on the street is there what do
you think is the biggest difference for
you in those two characters or just like
not character you're really I know it's
definitely a character I try to make it
a character yeah because like I think
that there should be like a blurred line
with that type of content or it's like
and that's what made its work so well in
the beginning was like I don't know
what's real I don't know what's a bit
guys I was blown away I told both of
them that I was like I've heard of you
guys at the streaming's when you won
like best show of the year and you
Franco we got invited back this last
stream is to announce the word to
present it yeah it's all come full
circle and I was like who are these very
excited kids that are and then I went
back and I watched
binge and I loved it and I got mad at it
because I wish that I had thought of
something like it because it was very
like Wonder Years means like jackass
means just like reality television meets
flossing and it was very cool and but it
also I was like how real is this versus
how scripted is this yeah that was what
was so interesting and kept me watching
is I kept wanting to try and find like
where the scripted parts were like where
they're like linked together the new
find like when are they being real when
are they being like is this really just
a natural like car ride that they're
having or is this like you know point A
to point B that to get there in the
scene yeah and a lot of the times we
didn't even know oh no truthfully like
we kind of just did things like it
became just turning the camera and back
then like Steve was editing everything
yeah that's it he came here and he
seemed stressed out we'll make this as
quick as possible because I know you
have to get back to doing the 10,000
hours of work literally like oh I have
to excuse me see I told you Birdman it's
perfect human human being relatable but
yeah back then it was literally just
like shoot whatever is going on like you
know do our thing like try to have an
angle yeah that we're doing like
whatever adventure going on and then
Steve like we would do it and I'd be
like that was just a fun time hang out
with the friends I don't know what
that's gonna become and then Steve would
find a story in it you know like it
became like documentary filmmaking in a
way when you you film so much like you
got it covered you get for a documentary
and then finding the story and there
comes a lot of in the editing yeah but
he's finding a mini documentary every
single night they're all true crime
that's actually what I describe our show
true crime it's very true and now you
guys are working with roosterteeth how
long has that been going on uh a year a
year has that what's the like biggest
change for you going from like working
independently to now working under this
kind of like company there's pros and
cons to that yeah 100% and the biggest
change like I had a lot of good changes
in myself from it I just
came a lot more responsible and I
learned how to hold myself accountable
or so when it comes to working teach me
because I'm gonna forget it like every
week I'm reteaching myself yeah I just
there were a lot of areas cuz we were
just a group of friends that were doing
this and we found some success in it
mm-hmm but it was a lot of skill but I
lost also a lot of luck that went into
it like capitalizing on just the moment
me yeah yeah and so it became like once
it became a real job with like a parent
company there were a lot of just areas I
realized weren't being filled that
needed to be like just build you know so
yeah I really like it was like okay
where do we need extra like work being
done and stuff like that and I tried to
like step up and do a lot more work
versus what I did before which was
literally like filling I would then just
act or whatever it seems like you put on
more of a producer hat oh yeah yeah and
it seemed I mean but and that's great
because I feel like there you guys each
seemed my impression of each of you is
that you all kind of have like strong
suits in different ways look director
producer talent whatever it might be and
that kind of comes together really
cohesively yeah I think that especially
this past year like we've each kind of
fallen into that in many different ways
like I think Kim is one of the he's a
crazy person he's come his brain works
in crazy ways and makes connections that
I can't keep up with it takes me like
after he was on the podcast I was still
processing hours later at things that he
was saying in jokes that he was making
they literally flew by my face in my
brain like he's nuts it's not but you
guys are all catered to that way it's
it's almost intimidating to shoot with
you guys because you guys oh yeah I
remember yeah I've shot a couple things
with you guys and you your work ethic is
like bar none but awesome about that so
it seems like we know we're doing sure
maybe that's it maybe that's the facade
I always think that when we film with
somebody who like doesn't know what's
personally that well sure that I'm like
all right don't like terrify them
they're taking care of and they like
feel welcome here you know what I mean
and like when we filmed that with you a
few weeks ago we filmed in finished and
you left and I was like was that good
did she what she slept and was like was
that good like that's what you guys do
so well is you make something out of
what seems like nothing and that's like
I mean keep good luck to you keep going
that's an impossible task constantly
it's it's difficult it's counting has
there ever been an episode that's gotten
canned that hasn't seen the light of day
because you're like this is
inappropriate or one of us is not
comfortable um maybe not for that reason
but there have been a few that have just
gotten cut and not seen the light of day
just because it wasn't up to par yeah
there were a couple that you know when
we start working with roosterteeth we
like went on a really rigorous upload
schedule to six videos a week that's a
no it's insane and I I think we're gonna
kind of cut down in level a little bit
as you're spear and elder I think you
should for your own mental yes I have
anxiety meiosis watching how hard you
guys work with I'm like burnout is real
and like very precious beautiful brains
like treat them with nourishment yeah
it's it's it's nuts cuz there's like two
sides to you you know it's like put a
more content it pays off but then it
also like creatively drains you to the
point where you're just making things
and they're just putting out stuff
they're like do you really care are you
proud of it and people see through that
oh yeah yeah absolutely and it's hard to
keep that like facade on being like it's
all just fun when it's like no there's
so much work yeah and [ __ ] that goes
into it
well that's what I like I was listening
to your guys most recent podcasts on the
way over and they that must be nice for
you guys to kind of take off like your
character hats a little bit if that's
what you guys do and I try to talk as
like friends and humans to each other
because sometimes it does feel like a
very insular conversation that you guys
are happy like making dinner plans after
you don't have to say it on the podcast
sure but I like that you guys keep that
in because it makes it feel like you're
the friend that's all
so sitting at the table being like yeah
doc me I'll get ya okay have fun guys
yeah but it's also nice to hear you guys
talk about things that I'm sure you
can't like really get into on episodes
of the show as much and like actually be
each other and like have real points of
view and have real discussions with each
other yeah have you guys do you guys get
into like debates or arguments on that
mm-hmm yeah okay actually I think it was
two weeks ago maybe three weeks ago
I definitely like got upset with Steve
on the podcast on the pocket on the
podcast
really oh yeah about what
he just and this isn't throwing Steven
of the bus or anything like that he's
talked to him a million times about this
has since been resolved oh absolutely
I know I hate him actually great there's
a huge rift that can never be sealed
no he just like because I I'd love to be
like able to be James yes instead of
being the character times like right now
like yeah I'm the character I don't like
it I liked it like when I meet people or
I go to any like events or whatever do
content with other people when it's not
like supposed to be a fictitious super
funny thing yeah I like to be myself and
just talk about things you know it's a
very human desire to have yourself yeah
Steve though definitely likes to keep
that bit alive a little bit more so yeah
it's similar to me though he'll like
snap in and out of it when the time is
right yeah we kind of noticed that when
he was on here that he would go back and
forth you could tell it's like it's
exciting to be in the bit but then it
tires you a little bit you gotta like
recharge and be a human being for a
second yeah and Steve doesn't always do
that sometimes I'll just stay in it and
like he's really good at making it seem
real yeah and that's where all that
comes from like the blurred line of like
what's real what's not and he on that
podcast specifically he just kind of
kept like egging on this little like
for like fight that kid but keV and I
had gotten into like this solved hours
ago because keV and I like never fight
for more than like five minutes yes you
had a conversation it was a conversation
yeah and he kept trying to kind of egg
it on to get like more juiciness in the
podcast and I was like I was kind of
like no yeah like I don't want this
whatever and then he just kind of kept
going and then I finally like had to put
him in his place a little bit it's
really cool to hear like adult men like
actually have a conversation about
certain things
yeah do you guys have a safe word how do
you resolve things you just sort of get
through it yeah yeah I'm I'm like
extremely open with things like you oh
I'm like yeah I if I have an issue I'll
just simply say it yeah bring it up and
then we'll go from there
like I can't just bottle [ __ ] up if it's
like something some of them like talking
on a daily basis that's what therapists
would call healthy yeah healthy human
behavior all my therapist actually hates
me my therapist doesn't return my calls
yeah that was her actually just ignored
just letting me know she's blocked me on
every okay I know you just stopped
calling me okay I haven't called you is
this homeless person I found on the end
of the road I gave her a burner phone
with three minutes okay we're gonna take
a quick break when we get back I gotta
talk to you about Vinny I got talked
about the girlfriend I got talked about
this merch I got to talk to you about
CrossFit so we'll be right back with
that's the Hot Pockets already
[Music]
too deep this episode of not too deep is
brought to you by Lisa they believe that
a bed is more than just a place to sleep
it's a place for relaxation and rest and
they believe that everybody has the
right to rest that's where they make
- awesome mattresses plus accessories
and bases to give your body the deep
rest it needs the all foam Lisa mattress
is new and improved featuring cooling LS
a 200 foam for enhanced pressure relief
for side sleepers I don't even know what
that means but it sounds technologically
advanced and fun and they have a
superior hybrid mattress that is the
perfect combination of foam and spring
for pressure relief and edge to edge
support their mission is to provide a
better night's sleep for everybody and
from day one at Lisa has set out to
create a company with heart that's why
they donate one mattress for every 10
they sell to organizations that work in
causes like foster care prevention and
to date they've donated more than 32
thousand mattresses through more than
1,000 nonprofits and I now sleep
annalisa and I gotta say it's absolutely
wonderful one of the things that no one
prepares you for in your adult life is
choosing a mattress so hopefully this
endorsement helps you figure that out
for a little bit and you can get 15% off
your entire order at Lisa comm / grace
use promo code grace that's le esa.com /
grace promo code grace support for
today's episode comes from bareMinerals
creators of clean beauty purity and
formulation and uncompromising
performance have always been the guiding
principles of bare minerals because they
believe that makeup and skin care should
make your skin better not just better
looking
what a philosophy and this has been the
bareMinerals philosophy since they began
the clean beauty revolution in 1995 with
their best-selling original foundation
which offers creamy lightweight
buildable coverage that's naturally
luminous the clean formula is made with
only 5 good for skin ingredients all
minerals including non-chemical SPF
protection makeup so pure you can sleep
in it and it actually improves your skin
over time what that's insane
it's everything your skin needs nothing
it doesn't for bareMinerals to be clean
without compromise means good for skin
formulas with proven performance like
every bare minerals product it's 100%
cruelty free better yet both the
original and that loose powder
foundations are available in 30 shades
so upgrade to clean beauty products use
the foundation finder at their minerals
calm to find your perfect match and
first time customers will get 15% off
when you use the promo code not too deep
that's bare minerals calm promo code not
too deep n ot t oo d EE P for 15% off
your first purchase bare minerals the
power of good Elliot this is for you
know the only one that still worked at
SourceFed when I was there was Steve Z
Oh cuz he came in later right yeah he
was there the whole time I think he came
on later than Joe Lee I think Joe Lee
and Elliott all came on at the same time
and then Steve came a little bit later
and then stayed a little bit later than
them you'd know much more than me that's
my general understanding I don't know
the time I don't know sometimes they
talk at me and I don't listen to them so
the only like so Zaragoza was yes Steve
Z was there and then the only like the I
remember he made me laugh the hardest
I've ever laughed while working there
yeah no doubt they did uh-oh is it some
prank call thing Steve like called
a Walmart yeah this sounds person was
like pretending to call out sick and it
was the funniest thing I I was on the
floor like crying like you well you
can't inhale yes you're just like it was
unreal he's a magical angel of hilarity
like he's he can just wear a punch and
stand in front of me and I will think
it's the most delightfully hilarious
thing in the universe and he's just
genuinely loving his fashion I it's so
pure and so beautiful and so sweet
also I love people that are generous
with their laughter like he also really
hard at things and that just makes me
laugh oh yeah
absolutely you need that yeah that just
helps the energy in any situation yeah
like knowing that like I'm around people
who are gonna be laughing yeah I'm gonna
be laughing together like also Mike
Falzone oh yeah yeah Mike's laugh is so
contagious because I like say something
that was kind of just like a funny
remark but wasn't it to be like yeah I
feel like he is the same sort of thing
that like Harley Morenstein however they
laugh like little Catholic schoolgirls
is so infectious Serena I love it so
much
okay talk to me about Vinnie Vincent
Vincent I call him vineyard vineyard
this is your dog I'm going to show you
this yes please please what is this a
golden retriever yeah oh my god how old
is he he's gonna be two in like a week
so he's a baby
he's still the energy he's always like I
can tell he's always gonna be like Bega
look at this beautiful salt yeah he's so
precious what made you get Vinnie um he
well we wanted a dog we really wanted to
go in retriever but we also wanted to
like not just like let's get her a
breeder yeah yeah I mean um so we've
been kind of looking out for any dogs
that were being fostered or anything
like that and came across it came across
him randomly one day like a year and
nine months ago
oh yeah basically and he uh he was given
up because the owner of his mom had
gotten cancer and the dog had just given
birth to three puppies and so she had to
give up the puppies yeah and so we went
to the foster home go check it out and
one of them was already gone and so then
it was Vinny and the other one that was
there and the girl came out and put
fitting in my arms and I was like a bean
he was this big baby a little bean just
cute fluffy little floppy puppy no just
like
I can't believe this like I could
instant connect yeah and the other one
was like wait it was like whining and
crying stupid son of a [ __ ] you [ __ ]
rekt bench so we took him home that
night and it was like a very very hard
like four or five months really yeah cuz
I mean anticipate no in you're in an
apartment and okay we were just like we
have to do this yeah because when is
this gonna be an opportunity again we
wanted a dog so bad so we got him and he
was like just the constant diarrhea okay
it's like babies they're like babies
yeah they're constantly just Shing like
the worst kind of [ __ ] it's not normal
[ __ ] it's not like a no it's it's the
kind that you gotta scrub up exactly and
living in an apartment we had one of
those grass patches
oh no no great in theory but then it
just gets wet and heavy smells like
death yeah there's piss and [ __ ] yeah
and flies and sunlight on it yeah I know
we had a great time though so you went
through the trenches with this puppy
then I knew I was like get him through
this stage where he's like seven months
yes you got him when he was eight weeks
old that's so nuts my I got my dog when
she was like ten months so I missed that
puppy puppy face what kind do you she's
a mix she's kind of a [ __ ] but she's
got a cute face don't we all that's
actually how I'm described
yeah that's your Twitter bio cute face
but I could be a [ __ ] [ __ ] but I knew
once we gone and passed that puppy stage
he was gonna be just a lifelong partner
I mean Trevor's I mean I don't think I'm
perfect ever known of a bad golden
retriever no and if they are bad or
aggressive or anything they're mixed
with something oh yeah that makes me
here we don't know if he's pure but we
think he is
yeah but he's kind of small like he's
yeah I'm on your Instagram and I didn't
realize he was a golden retriever
because he looked a little more
miniature yeah he's tiny but like he's
also two years old yeah he's two years
old and he's just like there's actually
filled golden retrievers and
it's the other one the other kind
there's like two kind of branches so
filled retrievers are less common and
they're smaller and more slender as I
think they come from like maybe like
hurting or something in the past so he's
like we think he's feel golden retriever
so just like you know I mean it's more
apartment handleable and it's like a
goldfish when you keep a goldfish in a
small tank it doesn't grow so we raise
them and apartments are getting grow
you're binding your dog yeah he loves it
do you bring him into the office um
sometimes I really like to not have
extra responsibilities when I'm at work
yeah that's so we have like a great dog
sitter that watches him he's got all
those friends there that's great I
prefer to do that that's cute
okay you started CrossFit is this real
I've gone three times okay first of all
why CrossFit why not okay
fair genuinely though because my
girlfriend started going a month before
me it's it's like a CrossFit class it
was like five six people oh that's nice
intimidated by the bigger classes no I
don't want to do that like I would be
down and do a private one-on-one if it
wasn't so expensive but the last thing
it's like a really good deal this little
gym near my house it's like a CrossFit
gym cool and so my girlfriend started
going a month before and was just like
this is really like helping me just it's
so much easier to work out when you're
just there with somebody being like do
this when you have accountability to
someone and it's out of your brain and
they're just telling what to do you if
and that's my biggest problem is just
holding myself to like a strict order of
whatever yeah but so I've gone three
times now and it's great I die every
single time there you go yeah well
that's i watched recently on a flight
back the last flight I head back to LA I
was like scrambling for any source of
entertainment to avoid any work I had to
do and there was a documentary about
CrossFit Games like the International
CrossFit Games on the TV oh yeah on the
TV that's what you chose to watch that's
what I chose to watch instead of I don't
know ant-man yeah no I didn't watch
ant-man
I chose crusted over Paul Rudd okay look
I'm not proud of it but here's the
outcome I loved
I was watching and getting ready in my
head - like sarcastically hate it make
fun of it like [ __ ] on it completely all
of these people are the most joyous
people I've never seen it's like a cult
they're all so supportive of each other
they're the most physically fit beings
I've ever seen I was texting Elliot the
whole time like making jokes about this
documentary being like yeah then they're
gonna like carry a tractor through a
swamp and have to walk on their hands
for a mile and then they had to do that
like later it's this [ __ ] thing like
they like oh my tits it's unreal like
you look at things and you're like okay
that's doable and then you start doing
you're like what but you also know oh my
god this is gonna make me a superhero
yeah like I'm not trying to get like
super ripped or built or anything I just
want to get in like good shape just be
capable of like lifting and exactly and
not be winded yeah all the time we're
tired yeah all the time for no reason
are you lifting tires
no okay what's the craziest like thing
they have you doing so far I don't think
this class gets too crazy
uh-huh like I'm sure there's yeah it's
kind of just like the thing I like about
it is like I think it's called a super
set that they do where they're like
there's this exercise this exercise and
this exercise
mm-hmm you do a set of that a set of
that a set of that and then you kind of
go in that rotation instead of like okay
just do a bunch of lifting like that
keeps it interesting yeah and each one's
kind of working a different part so
you're you're it's more efficient I feel
like you're working a few different
areas rather than just like to do biceps
just leg day yeah yeah no days off no
days off but I cancelled one of mine
last week well you know
cheers to when this episode comes out
you will be a contender in the CrossFit
Games yeah and we're knocking on what
about how was the horse search no look
you were okay can you give us any
insight on what this was
that's really funny that was just such a
random thing yeah so Jamie you know
Jamie yeah yeah one of our producers he
cuz we're always like figuring out ideas
and activities to go do and he's like
yeah we're spec writing like there's a
this is just an idea for an episode yeah
and
the funny thing too is kids like deathly
allergic to everything
oh yeah thank you every animal gives him
like in intense allergies
and we always have dogs in our office
but horses apparently like just really
attack him like Oh are the most in jest
like he wouldn't horse burger with his
wife and was just like dead I am it like
Holliman a burp beautiful yeah so we
just wanted to do like horseback riding
but Jamie called a few places and there
ain't no offense to people who love
horses or have horses or have been
around horses of course people are very
particular particular yeah that's the
perfect word that's not the word I was
gonna say like III didn't hear him on
the phone but what Jamie said is just
like yeah you know I asked if we could
like film with the horses and relied and
film while we're riding and stuff like
that like obvious we're gonna [ __ ]
pay to ride the horses sure and the lady
says why would you do that who's gonna
want to see that you don't want like
that doesn't make sense to you don't
exposure because this is um was this a
horse riding I don't know what you call
it ranch farm stable that people the
public can do yeah it was like a place
where you go right over so yeah I don't
think you had to like have your own
horse sure but by default you're
promoting this could come to in a place
like that we go to we obviously like
we're like this is where we are going
we're not just like taking advantage of
them yeah and also we're paying you
right for your service yeah to allow us
to ride your horses it's your business
and she said why would people want yes
oh my god it was just like a few places
were just very like particular be saying
that it's gonna be a new word and that
was just so surprising that like that it
seemed like that little nook of a
community of horseback riding with very
like their precious about taking their
horses yeah and I understand that
they don't want you to harass the horses
they don't want you to exploit the
horses you know what I actually I can't
promise that kid wasn't going to exploit
[Laughter]
room to stand up she knows she must have
known who we were concerned did a quick
google and no no wants to see I trust me
our horses suck okay well yeah you
wearing a hat right now but you still
got your blonde hair going oh hell yeah
okay it was frosted tips
those frosted you look very mark McGrath
[Laughter]
impetus for the blonde hair impotence
I just wanted to do it I wanted to do
that for a while you know I'm like I'm
still young yeah oh really
okay never done my hair I just was like
yeah what's the maintenance like for you
now as a fellow brunette that dyes her
hair blonde you're unnatural like me yep
I'm searching for something more no it's
very fun though
like I just like to style the style of
it like it's just it's cool and I really
like having the brown like you know and
everything plans for future colors etc
no future colors I probably blot like
daya blonde again yeah I might read I
like next week or something Jim tattoos
yeah for okay oh this is what I was
listening to on the podcast that you
guys just did on the way over that you I
think clay and Steven were like they got
tattoos and they can't talk about them
their parents or something oh yeah yeah
do they come from very conservative
families is that the deal
no I think that Steve didn't want
Alyssa's parents this one will mean him
have kind of matching tattoos the find
true I put a little 7 next to mine but
he has that but like a little bit bigger
on this one it's wildly non offensive oh
yeah
okay absolutely I just don't like
tattoos I don't know I just don't think
that he like even wanted to deal with
the what-if of it bad but um and then
Kip I think was just like I think he got
his first one when he was like 16 okay
somehow in prison I don't know if that's
a joke or not no it is okay okay I mean
he told us a crazy story about he didn't
specify that was a stripper he tells the
story about basically he is friend in
Canada was still in Canada
Betty like took oh don't woman home to
her house and was having sex with her
while his friend robbed her he didn't
know and I was like what it's insane and
really like colours this whole history
missus very like conservative but like
funny innocent pure human I was like you
got some get some darkness - yeah I
think he was just like from what he
tells me about his past in Canada was
like he just came from the type of like
area where all the they were all just
[ __ ] like did you whatever yeah they
were like but also you get to drink is
drinking age 18 in Canada I don't know I
think so yeah so it's like they're
drinking by the time they're 14 it's
like okay any ideas for future sure your
pint short films yeah mmhmm yeah no
that's something that's been like can
you talk about any of them or like any
just general thoughts on it well like
there's definitely future shorts that
we're gonna be doing cool like for sure
you would mention that you guys are
working on music album is kind of stuff
- yeah cool yeah we yeah we're doing
like we're just trying to find all those
different avenues of like stuff that we
want to do to fulfill ourselves and we
might be making some changes - oh yeah -
our content yeah we'll see I think by
the time this podcast is out you guys
will see you'll have changes will have
already been made yeah
cool I mean that's you gotta kind of
shake things up I think on a personal
level just say you stay interested in
making content and then on an audience
level so people get to see you guys
evolve and grow absolutely yeah ya know
the the fun thing is though is when the
audience doesn't want to see you grow oh
that's funny don't want you to change at
all they want you to remain 2010 self
for the rest of you yes because here's
the thing that they always say about us
and I'm sure you for this a [ __ ]
million times this this video like they
don't feel like season 1 videos [ __ ]
season 1 anymore yeah [ __ ] crew and
change yeah guys is that the most
bothersome content or comment for you
yeah yeah my thing is like I understand
there's always like the whole this was
like a very good time in this short
contents mm-hmm you know age or whatever
the [ __ ] I'm in Bergen god bless get it
out take your time but there's like
growth is the most important thing
especially when it comes to [ __ ] art
yep and like life in general yeah you
grow you change you have different
things inspire you have different
passions you have different desires and
stuff like that and like if things they
would also complain if it stayed exactly
the same yeah so there's like there's no
helping or pleasing everyone yep never
never and like that's just the thing you
find out first in this industry I think
is that you will never in a million
years please everyone even if you have
just a widely regarded amazing show that
you're doing there's always many people
there like well this is very derivative
of everything's derivative of something
yeah no ideas you're talking to no ideas
original you you're you find inspiration
in something and then you turn that
inspiration into your own thing yep
easily 100% I totally agree with that
I also feel like I've learned that
channels are like your channel is like a
teenager going through puberty you know
like there's going to be a change that
happens like people might like the
person before they're in puberty and the
puberty stage where you're changing a
little bit is awkward uncomfortable for
yourself and the audience some hair in
places you know why
the voice cracks here and there people
don't know how to like interpret it but
then you're gonna end up as like this
kind of like fully fledged
post-pubescent like adult adolescent
person yeah and then the people gonna be
like oh cool I like what this hatched
into exactly yeah it's just about the
time and like it's unfortunate it's
interesting talking to you because I
know you've been through every single
possible like ups and downs or whatever
that even exists yeah like for us we've
been going through kind of like a low
kind of good stuff that's difficult it's
the first thing that I've ever really
worked on that it's been like a personal
project that I'm invested in it's found
any like success and stuff and so we're
like the things to get a little bit
lower it definitely hits you oh it's the
first time that things get low it is the
worst feeling because you feel out of
control your general and then you also
feel like oh it's like maybe I took for
granted how great things were going and
you just imagine that this is it's
impossible for us to come down from this
and then it starts happening there's a
total freak out moment but that's when
you need to pivot because I think when
people what people do wrong is they
freak out and then rely on the thing
that they that got them their success in
the first place and try to go back to
doing that yeah where they stopped where
they stopped and I think what you guys
like the idea of this is not gonna last
forever like the pivots gonna create a
new audience or generate new eyes and
then also keep the eyes that really care
about the growth of your channel more
interested yeah absolutely and like
that's not a Content you guys put out
like yeah that's what I want to cut that
[ __ ] down yeah for real never ready
talked to like we all like as far as the
team goes we're on the same page and
I've already like talk to our upper yeah
uh flike that like we can't we have to
cut this down we have to make it like
just quality stuff yeah like and it'll
save your brains like you guys will have
more fun producing less but better
content than trying to just force [ __ ]
out of your brains because you have you
have to yeah yeah and that's something
that we hardcore learned this past year
yeah is like it's everyone always says
that but it's literally quality over
quantity yeah that's the
thing it really is and that you don't
you can't learn it unless you'd like
feel it and do it and experience it and
then you're like yes yes yes I see right
yes these these things these things the
same way people say you can't love
anyone else until you love yourself
that's true PAH maybe we should all just
have RuPaul teach us how to run our
YouTube channels okay he's like a savant
I'm like the algorithm you can do
everything okay we're good take one more
quick break when we get back we have a
ton of Twitter questions and Instagram
questions my god oh my god the internet
has spoken and they want to know things
James we'll be right back with more not
too deep let's get something straight
yeah teeth smile direct Club straightens
your teeth for 60% less than braces with
invisible aligners sent directly to you
you simply go online and you book a free
3d scan at one of their smile shops or
you can order an at-home impression kit
then they'll email a preview of your new
smile and once you get your aligners one
of smile direct club's duly at licensed
doctors will check in on your progress
every 90 days visit smile direct club
comm for real before-and-after photos
from some of the five hundred and fifty
thousand plus satisfied grin errs that's
cute that home satisfied Greeners and
exclusive to you our beautiful listeners
you can get $100 off your invisible
aligners when you go to smile direct
club.com
slash podcast and use the offer code
grace 100 you also get a $25 Amazon gift
card with a free 3d scan at one of our
smile shops or a $25 rebate on an
at-home impression kit that's $100 off
at smile direct club.com
slash podcasts offer code grace 100
smile direct club.com slash podcast
offer code grace 100
hey guess what I'm gonna assume you said
what so here we go
dropped is a free app that gives up cash
rewards for the shopping you do every
single day you link your debit and
credit cards when you sign up you select
the stores you shop with the most and
you earn points each time you spend
there you can redeem points for gift
cards to places like Amazon Sephora
Lululemon and many more with drop you
can earn them a team from brands that
are entirely relevant to you and your
preferences you're able to earn across a
number of brands so you can accumulate
points quickly especially since the
brand's you're earning points from are
the ones you spend with every day it's
easy to link your cards and then earn
points whenever you spend the app works
in the background to recognize your
transactions and reward you for those
purchases every time as someone that you
know is a most fond of human interaction
to be able to be encouraged with points
and rewards to shop online as I normally
do every day this is perfect and for a
limited time if you head to the App
Store or Google Play and sign up for
drop using my code grace you will
receive a $10 Starbucks gift card right
away what a treat
make sure you link a debit or credit
card to the app when you sign up to
redeem your reward we're back James hey
formerly SourceFed kindly formerly
SourceFed currently sugarpie 7 ok we
have a bunch of Instagram and Twitter
questions but before we get into those
I'm going to ask you the two questions
asked every guest that's on the podcast
and the first is who okay shoot delay
between them
okay hmm who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at
cold spaghetti yeah mm-hmm like it's
cooked but then it's had time to cult be
cold yeah yeah
my father oh okay Wow think that I'll
ever do that in general sure I mean this
is these are hypothetical totally yeah
but also they can become realities it's
just up to you okay I can't control what
you do I'm gonna take father as your
final answer and continue on with no
follow-up questions as to why okay it
all started when I was every guess is to
tell us your worst pants shooting story
or like close call hmm but you can only
use three words or three small phrases
some mine is college jogging front lawn
nice mm-hmm I'm not I'm not following
yeah thank God no one was following me
at the time okay thought art wasn't yeah
people's that don't trust the fart and
that I think especially when you have
diarrhea debilitating food poisoning so
far okay let's get into I usually take a
bunch of Twitter questions but I asked
Instagram for one of the first times and
it's there's so many for you yeah and I
know sorry you're popular did someone
say no when you're an assistant at
SourceFed did you ever believe the
internet would take you this far no
truly really I had no like with
SourceFed like kind of like the
educational grounds for Internet for you
yeah yeah I didn't know [ __ ] about this
industry like I still don't but I know
more than I did but yeah that was
literally just to get a full-time job in
the entertainment industry yeah burping
again god bless good luck but I had no
like plan as to like I'm gonna do
YouTube or I'm gonna do something with
that with that space in order
to like build my career it just happened
that way and it's awesome yeah like it's
an amazing thing to have like a big
support of an audience like that yeah
you know but do you because there's it's
interesting because there's I feel like
two different types of creators creators
that haven't finished college or started
and never finished or just never went
and then creators that have the advice
for people do you have specific pieces
of advice for people that are getting
out of school that want to get into the
entertainment world at all is it like
just try do it yeah I think it's
literally just there are ways to like
get your foot in the door in a very base
level and I think that though that's the
most important thing is to just get your
foot in the door yeah no matter what it
is because if you truly want to work in
this industry or the entertainment
industry in general regardless of what
you know particular position if you get
your foot in the door you start
networking you start meeting like
meeting people that we're in the exact
same place you were at one point like
it's you you can't just sit at home and
like dream I hope it comes to you yeah
yeah cuz it could but it probably won't
yeah dream though absolutely dream but
don't just dream yeah like do something
about it
I also think that you guys don't with
like valley folk do it really well where
you align yourself with the people that
have a similar point of view and a
similar like sense of humor and then you
go from there
I think surrounding yourself with people
that creatively inspire you and like I
support you it's hugely important it's
so much easier said than done to find
those people yeah but once you do it's
like don't let them go it's really is
that like find people that inspire you
and are like-minded but also find people
to challenge you yeah like Steve is such
a like creatively talented person in so
many ways like musically like just with
storytelling he's it might take a little
bit to get those things out of him sure
but if he's in the right space he'll
create something that's just like holy
[ __ ] yeah and that inspires me like to
just work harder and and look more
inward in myself and be like what what
are these things that I
no so that I can develop them and stuff
like that project and it's like that
motivation where it's like they're
challenging you but they're also
motivating you to like do better yeah I
think have this sounds may be negative
but I don't mean it this way like have
friends that seem threatening in a way
like creatively threatening that they're
so good that it makes you want to be as
good as they are yeah I usually just
physically threaten them
I've sent so many ransom notes to my
friends and like in the books that they
write based on them or really it's
really impressive so you have movie
deals from it yeah are you becoming more
interested in making music versus
directing um I'd say that directing is
here and then musics just getting
clients just climbing but like directing
is still my passion like that's the
thing that I want to end up doing yeah
and so do you want to direct like
feature film yeah oh cool like a feature
film director I want to write but I
haven't put enough effort into writing
since college to lay that I feel like
that's grown necessarily you've been
busy
yeah been very busy and that's the thing
is like also when you're when you're
working on stuff and it becomes like a
job try to make every step work towards
your goal you know like that's why we
want to get back into like making more
short films and stuff like that because
and now like cutting down on content a
little bit like we want to do we're
gonna have more that time on the side
yeah cuz we're out we all want to do
film we don't want to do like the big
leagues you know right right right and
and you're gonna lose that time by
spending all of it making the short-form
content than burning your brain now
exactly yeah I don't think I wouldn't
have any time to even think about ideas
and stuff like that yeah with music I
I've gone like full like kid gene
with this with this music [ __ ] like wait
don't you have an alter-ego rap name
what was the thing that you Instagram
with tattoos all over your face Oh what
was that
oh that's aka ak-47 the god yep explain
this don't know that's not well so we
did this sketch my favorite sketch we've
ever done yeah we're was just like
parroting like the genius verified
videos yeah yeah and so we were like a
band like a supergroup mm-hmm called for
one one yep like four and then one like
wo n yeah one like Oh any so for one one
mm-hmm and I was the rapper of the group
yep and a ka ak-47 to God but my
Christian name is Bartholomew - like to
me like that sketch that we made was
just like the most cohesive thing that
we had made in so long and we all were
so like happy with it yeah it was made
because it was it looks just like those
jaws videos in every way shape and it
was just like amazing
well these characters be making more
appearances potentially okay okay you
don't have to spoil anything for us we
we know we potentially might be
developing an entire series based on
that well [ __ ] okay exclusive they're
definitely doing an entire spin-off
series with these characters I take
lying it's full truth someone to know
what's the dumbest thing you've ever
done that didn't end up in a sketch I
feel like you guys use a lot of the
things that you shoot um I don't imagine
that there's much on the cutting I can't
think of anything that's like really
stands out as like maybe I did something
super stupid and then our editor didn't
put it in the video or something yeah
there's definitely like jokes or
different little bits that are cut out
just for the sake of time because we
want to put out well like 15 20 minute
videos every day
yeah I can't think of anything
specifically I'll come back to that sure
yeah I forget about it someone's know
best awkward middle school story
you
you were perfect in middle school
impossible to find a story you were the
coolest kid in town oh yeah so cool
oh but also going along with this
someone to know have you ever been given
a wedgie no okay
they've been given a wedgie most
embarrassing or most awkward thing in
middle school it can be high school - it
could be college - most Awkward school
story
we can also come back to that come back
to it someone to know when are you
bringing back freestyle Friday I don't
know is this something you did I did
just like little things like months and
months ago bro just like try to
freestyle over a beat and so weak that
just work out like for real yeah okay
I'm really like I'm really into hip-hop
and that's like the kind of music that
I'm trying to make like cuz you really
suppose it uncultured yeah and that was
your first original song like
independently of sugar pie no it's it's
sugar bun okay Steve produced that beat
and then I rapped on it cool like I
that's like my my thing now is like I
spent so much time on FL Studio like
trying to learn who is how to produce
music and it's like fully in my brain
right now we're like every song I listen
to I'm like able to pick apart like all
the different things that are going on
oh really
yeah and it's kind of weird yeah like I
I feel like I'm listening to music
differently now but it's like with film
like since I went to film school and
like I've been making a little [ __ ] like
you look at TV and film differently
kinda in a way like I never want to get
to the point where like I can't enjoy or
be entertained by that [ __ ] anymore but
it's it's cool to like understand like
the technical things that were done in
certain songs you've a different way of
analyzing it yeah yeah well with that
someone was asking about what your
college experience was like it was cool
yeah um it was weird
it was interesting like it was great as
far as like once I got into all film
classes and that was like my total focus
it was amazing yeah just like that's
where I made some great friends around
the like-minded people um made really
cool [ __ ] cuz like we were all just I
had this group like in the film program
and we were all like really good friends
and we would always work on projects
together even if one of us weren't in
the class we'd be like come work on this
project with us yeah I mean and
we were all just so down to like
experiment the [ __ ] out of [ __ ] yeah
like we did this I'm gonna lose it that
ball yeah but it wasn't just like let's
just make like there's having a
conversation it was like no we did this
one where it was called after okay and
it was about this guy who overdosed it's
like a short film yeah it's like a
little short at this guy over us we shot
it on film - oh cool yeah it was nuts
where the [ __ ] is that I was gonna say
is it online anywhere um no well space
if you find it - put it on the Internet
so it's about this guy like overdoses
and then he it's like he's floating
through like different parts of his life
and we shot it all like actively going
back it kind of like Enter the Void okay
but not that intense show like we had
because I acted in it - and like I was
like on a dolly like on a track like
going through the house like and there
were these other scenes set up and it
was all like it was cool
that's cool yeah we just we're like
let's just go all out and like try this
crazy [ __ ] and shooting on film is
difficult yeah what's four people that
don't know like how what's the
difference between shooting on digital
versus film I'm so digital you usually
have a lot of Auto settings if you're
not like super in tune with like what
the different like f-stop are ISO is and
stuff like that joy but with film unless
you're using like a top-of-the-line
camera which is we weren't we were using
like an old our ESR - just from like the
early 90s okay um you have to have
everything perfect going into it and or
or you're [ __ ] or good after the point
yeah no not in the same way at all like
the exposure is extremely important and
like even just changing like the film
out and putting like a new role in it
has to be in complete darkness cuz
usually like this bag that you put the
camera in that's like this big-ass like
leather bag and you're in there and you
have to do it all by hand without seeing
it and like take the thing I put it in
load it level really close in [ __ ] yeah
that's nuts
yeah I'd like to see a digital film of
someone changing out actually yeah
but then you're just taking out the SD
card
would you shoot on film again mm-hmm
yeah do you prefer it no no no I but I
have like I only shot I think three
things on film okay but I would love to
like I have such a respect for the
filmmakers around today that are like
very adamant on still using film like
entertain Oh Christopher Nolan like
they're very much so like Chris Nolan
your old bud yeah yeah is there someone
that you would fanboy over seeing now
that you haven't ever seen in Hollywood
yet or at an event or anything probably
many I don't know if I'd ever fanboy I'm
not that kind of person yeah like
especially if it's somebody that I
respect a lot for their work
I would like try to figure out a way to
just have a normal conversation with
them yeah um present yourself as a human
being yeah another human being
yeah yeah that's pretty cool thing to do
here that works for some people I think
probably Martin Scorsese if I ever saw
you know casual bro names someone to
know for you and clay what's the worst
hair choice that you've made in the past
that you wish you could undo Oh so at
the end of senior year in high school
this might be the awkward awkward is
more so just like looking back I was
like why the [ __ ] was my hair like that
okay I cuz I have very like thick hair
choice when it grows along it becomes
thicker okay romance novel cover okay
and I just wanted to like have kind of
like I was a huge stoner in high school
shocker and I just wanted to have like
longer hair yeah just like you wanted
luxurious wavy hair but looking back on
it no no it was not it was just like a
lot debated my facebook because of it oh
no not because of that
because of other reasons someone say no
have you ever left a show theater movie
etc early I've ever walked out of a
movie I almost did what movie I almost
walked out a mother oh really
I have never seen it did you guys see
mother yeah did you guys both almost
walk out of it yeah no she liked it
we're half we're split you liked it you
hated it
we're split down the middle okay it's a
two-to-one vote on good verse bad well
what about it in the most in the
quickest way possible I'm Christian
uh-huh and that movie disgusting
disgusting as far as like its
interpretation of like Christianity in
the Bible yeah interesting
it was just like aggressively bought
blasphemous okay yeah and it during
Aronofsky is like a very outward critic
of Christianity uh-huh and so I don't
think that's the story for someone like
him to tell yeah especially wouldn't
like like there are certain aspects of
it that were interesting but I just
think like it's so like visceral and it
attacks your senses and has you on the
edge of your seat like very much so
like invested in what's going on because
you don't know what's going on right and
then for me when the point came where it
was like oh [ __ ] this is what this is it
was it affected me okay yeah I felt like
I was uh like offensively yeah yeah like
I just felt like all my emotions were
like very invested in this right now
because it was it's very like compelling
the way the way he shot it and
everything it's very like right and
Jennifer Lawrence's face like you don't
know what the [ __ ] going on and it got
there and then I remember exactly the
moment but like I was kind of like
getting it the gist of what was going on
and I was like oh [ __ ] I felt like this
like anxiety just like reached up and I
was like ah this isn't what I wanted
from this and I'm pissed yeah I almost
walked out but I was like [ __ ] it I'm
already here I'm sitting in it and then
there's yeah you've seen it y'all know
yeah it's just there's some things and
just especially once you know what it's
about the metaphors of everything and
the way that they show it was just so
in-your-face
yeah like there's a lot yeah yeah
fan i have no reference point for it so
but i'll take your word for it
i mean watch it if you want well not
with that critique look watch hook for
the first time the other night so it
takes a lot for me to get to a movie
yeah i had no idea i thought people
channeling that we're just like sports
fans and it was like some basketball
player that I never knew Hornets yeah
okay no I could talk for a while but my
critiques of hook but we won't get into
that this is about you it was very
interesting it's sorry y'all and none of
the kids seem to care they're all like
ah cool
okay look we'll move on and then also
tink this adult woman finally became a
big can't revealed her love for the
other fellow adult man he was like you
know what rain check on that but also
not rain check like forever no see yeah
and then she's just left by herself yeah
so anyway so wants to know just sorry
about it I'm heated about it
what are you glad that changed about
yourself since starting sugar pine seven
um I definitely feel just more confident
in the work that I make really yeah yeah
like despite you know views going down
and stuff like that in those kind of
stand downs I just feel like once you
make a lot of something you become more
confident in what it is and more
comfortable like experimenting ah yeah
they broke coming on see this is a
bodily experiment right now your body's
experimenting with gaseous pressures and
we're good there you go I suppress it
yeah and it like more comfortable
experimenting with different things and
trying new things and you know just more
confident in myself in my abilities and
yeah I mean it's kind of the same thing
I'm really excited for you guys because
I feel like even though there is what
you know numbers are decreasing or
declining or whatever I think that's an
opportunity for you guys to kind of let
go and not care so much about that and
fully experiment and try new things and
realize like the true fans are gonna
stay with you and be excited for you and
then you're gonna feel more confident
and excited and fulfilled in whatever
you create and that'll bring new people
to you
so I think you guys are at a really cool
like pivoting moment yeah which is
really exciting to see what you guys do
yeah I feel like it's either it's one or
two things gonna happen I want to say
what they are
uh-huh well I'll leave it uh you guys
can try to guess what two things are
gonna happen there's gonna be a throuple
marriage between the three of you or you
know a three-person murder who knows
yeah who knows and becomes one giant
game a clue or we become the first-ever
actual human centipede oh yeah on
ironically yeah and we've actually
talked about this the exact placement of
everyone Oh what place are you so I'm a
oh you're the head yeah Oh Steve's be oh
yeah and then kids see but he's turned
around so they're a stylist okay but I
both don't have to go this is worth
exploring for you guys you know where's
the numbers going down you guys do what
makes you happy
yes D is actually animating it right now
cinema 4d like super realistic James we
reached the end of the podcast but
before you go we want to give you the
gift that every guest gets for giving us
their time it's a personalized fortune
cookie just for you so cool you can open
it this mmm
we bought the fortune cookies the
fortune we might have created he's so
strong says get [ __ ]
we like to neg our guests sorry that's
my favorite line from Sean the dead
you've been sleepwalking as aka ak-47 to
God and therefore there are two arrest
warrants out for him in Arkansas in
Kansas please do not back there well
there you go so you gotta change your
life changes so much for having this has
been so fun thank you for being here
thank you for having thank you for
having me have you where can people find
you sugar pie and all the stuff you guys
are up to you can find me at James
DeAngelo's with a Z on Twitter and
Instagram and then sugar point seven
youtube.com slash sugar pine 7:00 and
then at official sp7 on Twitter
Instagram and yeah so yeah you guys
should check them out because obviously
they have a lot of great stuff in the
works and things are changing and
evolving and developing and it's gonna
be great so thanks again James thank you
not too deep good bye hey you home safe
everybody - deep deep deep not too deep
is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer and edited by
melissa demons writing by diane kang a
production assistants by Katrina Henning
post production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]